let's talk about the foods to counter
obesogens so what is an obesogen well it
is those things in the environment that
don't have to do with
calories they have to do with man-made
chemicals that contribute to being obese
i'm talking about things that are food
containers that you maybe will put in
the microwave baby bottles
toys plastics and their related
chemicals cookware as in nonstick teflon
and even cosmetics now what do all these
have in common well they give off
chemicals that mimic
estrogen and estrogen is one of those
hormones that make you fat so let's go
through some of the chemicals you have
bisphenol a bpa which is one of those
chemicals found in different plastics
then you have phthalites which are also
in plastics in other containers
and atrazine which is the most widely
used herbicide so it's in our food
unless you do organic then you have
other chemicals like pfoa which you're
normally going to see in those non-stick
pans like teflon then you have des
diethyl stevestrol now that's a drug
that has been banned but apparently it's
still in our environment to a certain
degree then you have ssris which are
serotonin selective reuptake inhibitors
better known as antidepressants and this
is why one of the side effects is waking
so let's get to the solutions one of the
things that you need to do is just be
aware
of what chemicals do what thus this
video
and number two there are certain foods
that you can start to eat that will
slowly detoxify estrogen from your body
using the hub of detoxification which is
the liver and so your liver has the
ability to turn these poisons into
harmless particles it's called phase one
phase two detoxification and to
stimulate more of this detoxification
process
the cruciferous vegetables are the best
solution now the second solution is
probiotics because the more diversified
microbes you have in your gut the better
you're going to be able to deal with
these poisons now if we combine
probiotics with cruciferous
we get sauerkraut and we also get
fermented vegetables which are really
good because they provide the prebiotics
the fiber as well as the probiotics so
just make sure you have some of these
foods in your diet on a regular basis so
you cannot just protect yourself from
getting fat but to avoid these chemicals
that create a lot of other issues
so if you're enjoying my content which i
hope you are
and you're applying this knowledge to
your health and you have a success i'd
really appreciate you sharing your
success story so click the link down
below to my website where you can upload
your success story so you can help
inspire others